difficile de rater l'ère du poulet de
bresse sur l'a39 une volaille géante de
plus de 20 mètres de haut
rappel aux vacanciers qu'une pause
déjeuner s'impose depuis 20 ans ce
restaurant d'autoroute propose aux
touristes de goûter le produit phare du
département de l'ain certains l'été ne
s'arrête d'ailleurs que pour ça ces
poulets obligatoire à midi ah oui
obligatoires rien d'autre on mangera des
pâtes en italie mais ici on mange du
poulet
il a bonne réputation donc on va goûter
c'est la première fois et j'espère qu'on
va se régaler nous on n'est pas du site
d'angkor
on voit la différence celle où chaque
année
cet erp unique en france cuisine 12000
poulet un quart est consommée en juillet
août à l'occasion des chassés-croisés
d'été juste mais il voulait donc qu'on
nous vendons sur la cafétéria viennent
d'une coopérative régionale dont c'est
un groupement de plusieurs plusieurs
éleveurs et après donc sur la boutique
nous vendons du poulet de bresse frais
emporter qui vient essentiellement de
notre notre fournisseur et une dizaine
de kilomètres de chez nous on travaille
avec lui depuis 20 ans
car après avoir dégusté le poulet de
bresse le touriste peut aussi l'acheter
16 euros 95 le kilo le sac isotherme et
même fourni vous êtes arrêté exprès ah
oui oui vous avez déjà goûté au moins
non mais je sais que c'est le meilleur
coulé au monde
tous les restes des clients qui
réservent leur poule et à l'avant ce qui
nous téléphonent pour pour le mettre de
côté pour que être sûr de leur parti
avec son poulet et ça peut partir
en allemagne où l'angleterre avec 4
millions de personnes qui s'arrêtent
chaque année air du poulet de bresse
l'un ne pouvait rêver meilleure vitrine
pour ses volailles les seuls au monde à
bénéficier du label aop